to introduce our next category we once
again go to France this time to a movie
set just outside Paris where the
projectionists assures us will find the
enchanting Academy award-winner of Roman
holiday miss Audrey Hepburn
the next awards are for the best
achievement in costume design this award
is not only a great interest to every
actress who depends upon the artistry of
the designer to help her create her role
but it is also important to women
throughout the world historical or
modern every film with beautiful clothes
launches some new trend in fashion all
of us are indebted to the talent
imagination and research that go into
the designing of costumes for motion
pictures Thank You Audrey or as we
switch to know your account number three
six two four nine zero five now to
present the award
for something whoa several years ago a
very expectant mother waddle down these
aisles to receive her Oscar for a while
we were all a little nervous that there
might be an extra ward well today her
little boy is eight years old and the
Oscar she received for a lyric
performance and on the waterfront is
just a few weeks older ladies and
gentlemen Miss Eva Marie Saint
that we have a little girl too but she
was born during the Academy offseason
t-thanks I saved us all a lot of
suspense black-and-white costume design
for the best costume design in black and
white we will show you the designer
sketches and the nominees are
Don fell your days of wine and roses
eat it head for the math and shop deputy
bail
smarty America
Naomi
for whatever happened baby Jake
and the winner is nama cult for whatever
happened to Baby Jane
my deepest appreciation to Robert
Aldrich and all the baby chains the
nominees for costume design of a color
picture are Bill Thomas for bon voyage
Laurie Kenny for gypsy your are the
chickens for Meredith Willson's
a wonderful world of the Brothers Grimm
for the winner for best costume design
of a color picture is Mary Wales for the
wonderful world of the Brothers Grimm
thank you very much